who was working with the web in 2008
please raise your hands okay so do you
guys remember what happened 2008 like
some big deal some guy named html5
arrived so this was the first time that
the html5 spec arrived and everything
just went crazy right when html5 arrived
you know it was this thing that will
save all of us and on 2009 there was
this interview with Ian Hickson the guy
that wrote the specification and he said
that html5 would would be ready in 2022
and I don't know if you remember this
but like just the tech world and the
media they portrayed it html5 as this
thing that would be ready like 10 years
from now or much more than this and and
you as a developer you probably thought
that so why am and I'm just like
studying this thing if it's not gonna be
ready very soon so that was like really
complicated really messed up in 2010
Steve Jobs wrote this open letter saying
that flash was not gonna run on on iOS
devices anymore and then html5 was the
answer if you wanted to build web
applications for iOS and that just like
the market went crazy when this thing
happened I don't know if you were
working with ActionScript at that time
working with the flash platform but I
remember lots of people just like going
crazy and like switching jobs and and do
you know all those kinds of things
in 2011 html5 got this amazing logo and
now html5 was like definitely a
superhero you know it was the thing that
was gonna save all of us and kill flash
kill all those crazy plugins and as
everything that starts to get popular in
2012 marks looking back gave this
interview
saying that our biggest mistake was
batting too much on html5 so that was
really crazy a lot of people I started
to think that html5 was not the answer
html5 what's something that you should
shouldn't be working on but you know
those those kinds of bad press happens
and later on in 2013 people continued
working with html5 and creating game
screeching creating all those kinds of
things all kinds of applications in 2014
this specification went to the
recommendation status so that means that
the w3c went through all the steps of a
specification can can go with and it was
ready and now what html5 is ready and
what should we do next you know so you
probably heard about SVG canvas
localstorage
WebRTC video audio drag-and-drop
geolocation all those amazing
technologies that came with html5 but
what now what happened between 2014 and
2016 that doesn't include react or a
[ __ ] or browserify what happened with
the the web platform and there was a
bunch of of things and that's the idea
of this talk to show some of the API
shows some of other things that happened
so we'll start with page visibility so
this API it's basically a very simple
way to ask if a page is currently
visible for the user or not so in the
past you could use events like on blur
on focus on a page but that was like
really a bad idea it was just a hack
because if you have like two tabs on the
same page and one two windows on the on
the on the same way on the same screen
and you would click on one the other
would be on blur so that was not a bad
that was not a good idea
so they came up with this specification
just to know if a page was visible or
not
and the way it works it's very simple
you add eventlistener
and then if it's hidden you do something
if it's visible you can do another thing
so that's pretty easy the specification
evolved a little bit one of the things
they're saying right now is there's this
new property called visibility state so
the idea is that you can identify other
kinds of status of a page so there's a
new attribute called link rel prefetch
prefetch something like that and then
you can prefetch a page so now you can
using this API you can identify it if
the page is pre rendering or not and
same thing if it's hidden if it's
visible you can do something on the page
so the browser support is pretty good
it's amazing actually
you can use it nowadays and but the
question is where to use it and I'm just
going to give you like this example
imagine you have like a player on your
page this is a video player and once you
start the video you can show like
feedback on the screen on your fav icon
for example if you open a new tab that
page is not visible anymore so you can
pause the video and once it backs again
you can play the video so you can do
this kind of experience for the user if
you're building a game that's a very
good idea because you don't want the
user to go to other pages and then that
weird sound keeps playing that's very
annoying actually and but this is also a
bad user experience imagine if YouTube
does this so that'll be a mess because
people will like be hearing a video in
one tab and if you go to the other it
will pause the video so it really
depends on what you're building online
state is another one so nowadays we can
identify if a user has connection or not
that basically it
and you can use this attribute called
navigator online if it's true you can do
something if it's false you can do
another thing and you can also listen
for those two events called offline and
online and that's pretty much it you
know that's the only thing the only
information you can have from the
network it is good for a lot of cases
but sometimes you need more more things
the browser support is pretty good as
well for this one and as I said that
there are more things that could be
exposed for a webpage and that's why
this network information API exists so
this is a different thing this is
something that it's being written and
being developed but the idea is that you
can identify things like if the user has
a 3G connection or if it's a Wi-Fi
connection how is the download speed
how's the upload speed those kinds of
things so if you're building a video
player or something that it's more
robust imagine you could just know if
the user is using 3G and then you just
decrease some of the images that you are
using I don't know there's a lot of
possibilities and where to use this so I
have this app called dev space
it's a tweet deck for for github so I
just created like a very similar you I
just like to attack and where you have
columns and every single column is a
github stream you know and the github
API is amazing but you cannot do
real-time with the github API so you
have to do pulling or that means that
you have to you from time to time
Santa HTTP request to the API and get
the information so from one minute to
another minutes you just send a request
for for the github API the problem is if
the user goes offline then he would have
like this app that is not like updating
or anything like that so imagine if you
just like turn off the Wi-Fi and then
show some some user feedback
hey your internet is offline and if you
connect again to the Wi-Fi you can show
something like okay you are connected
again and now you have some new results
so those are some like smaller things
that you can do to improve the user
experience and it's very useful if you
are building a dashboard where you're
fetching information from time to time
it's important for the user to know that
that information is up-to-date the other
one is the vibration API so this this is
very nice because we are used to have
like visual feedbacks when your phones
on our computers we can have some audio
feed backs as well but there's not a
form of tactile feedback and there's a
there's some really nice things you can
do with that the API is super simple
also you call like navigator that
vibrate and here's the value in
milliseconds so you can pass just like
thousand milliseconds if you want to
vibrate for a second and you can also
pass in pattern so you should pass like
at an array and you you say that okay
for 400 milliseconds you can vibrate and
then you wait 300 and then you vibrate
for another treat 300 and then you wait
so you can build those those things and
you can also stop the vibration if it's
runny so like you can imagine some crazy
people working with this they did like
the super mario fame where it would
vibrate and according to the to the song
the Star Wars swing the Go Go Power
Rangers that's my favorite one and
that's that's really crazy but that's
the some of the things people do I don't
know the reason but they do so the the
support is not the the best one but it
but it works and if it doesn't it
doesn't change the the experience and
here are some ideas on where to use it
for games this is a very straightforward
example I don't know if you remember
this game
windows 95 I guess someone parted to to
JavaScript and and I played this game on
my phone and I was just like playing
with that and then when it crashed it it
vibrates so this is like a very small
thing on the on the on the user
experience but it it was really really
good you know I felt the difference
because it was a more immersive
experience some other examples some more
tangible examples is a form validation
when the user submits a form you could
just like vibrates if it's invalid and
again you have the the visual you have
the visual feedback so why not putting
this extra thing that will make the
experience better
you can also detect the device
orientation so that's that's really
insane you can actually detect the
physical orientation of a device and the
way you do it it it's you again just
listen for event and it then you have
those three informations on your
callback the gamma the beta and the
Alpha and if you just like this is a
real code from an example that I will
show you can just like have an image on
your page you get this image you listen
for this event and then you get those
information and then you can combine CSS
transforms with that information so you
can just like rotate your element
according to the physical orientation so
let me show you how this works okay so
this is my webcam and I have a very
conservative demo here this is Trump's
face and then you can just rotate and
then according to my physical
orientation it will change so that's
pretty awesome rotating Trump's face
but how is the browser support so that's
pretty good as well
and you can use the nowadays in where to
use it you know you're not going to
rotate Trump's face all the time
so what are the possibilities I don't
know if you use the Facebook app but
this new feature the 360 photos or the
360 videos this is something you could
use you know as the user changes the
physical orientation of your device you
can just do something like this you know
so that's really not that's really nice
the other thing is messing up with your
clipboard I know you all love this when
you copy something from a page it puts
some other content on your clipboard you
can do that there's some new API to do
that and you can do like copying pasting
and cutting and this is now real in the
past you had to use flash this is this
was probably the most famous library
called zero clipboard but it relied on
flash and I remember using it or I
remember having this use case where I
needed copy to clipboard and I just like
I refuse to use this API that this
library because it had flash but now you
can do it and you have like three steps
to to do copying to clipboard the first
one this is a browser requirement you
have to have like some using Direction
you cannot trigger event you cannot fake
event you have to actually have the user
clicking so we can just add a listener
for click and then we need to do two
separate things one is selecting the
content and the other one is actually
copying it so this is the first and then
we have the Select function where we
imagine we have an inputs on your on our
application and then we we need to
select the content of this input you can
programmatically
select content from an input you can
just focus this
then you just select the entire content
so now this is exactly like selecting
with your mouse but we are doing this
program right programmatically and then
finally we can copy the content so we
just use this document dot exact command
copy and now that's it if there's an
error we have this strike catch that can
can get it and there's some other things
some events that you can listen like
copy cut paste but the browser support
for those events is it's pretty bad and
the first time I saw this API I was
really really disappointed it was so
complicated it was so bad so I decided
to create this clip or jas library it
went pretty viral I don't know if you
guys heard about it but I would say that
this is the best way to do it nowadays
that's that's the easiest way nowadays
to make a copy to clipboard the browser
support it's good there's just this
little guy over here the new ie and I'm
really mad that it's not supported yet
because people who open issues all the
time say hey it's not supported and it's
not my fault but but yeah it's almost
there the the the Safari technology
preview it already implemented but they
are waiting for the iOS release so Apple
has this crazy release cycle so they're
waiting for that and where to use it I
guess
those are the the most simple use cases
you probably use github already and when
you want to clone some repo you can just
clip click on this button then it's on
your clipboard or if you using the
bootstrap documentation you can just
click on copy to clipboard and instead
of copying the entire block of code you
can just click on this button and this
actually it's the alpha for
documentation which uses clipart yes
the other one is ambient light so this
one is crazy
you can actually get the ambient light
and capture the lights and sensitivity
you know and and you can just pretty
much know if it's Y if it's light or if
it's dark you can do those things the
API again pretty simple adamant listener
device light you have a callback and
then you get the value and the value
they have this weird property not
another property that the metric it's
called looks I didn't know it existed
but it it's a faints how they measure
light so you have this value and I
created this example it's a really
friendly example no big deal
we have this actually okay yeah so we
have this friendly ghost and now it's
there's some light here because it
captures the webcam but if I turn off
the lights
if I turn
that's crazy that's a great example but
yeah you can do those things this API is
changing they are now creating this new
one called generic sensor so they are
putting some some other API is inside of
that and one of them is the ambient
light so the API will look like this in
the future
so you have to like instant shade a new
ambient light sensor you start the
sensor and then you have event to detect
if the image is if the ambient light
changed or not so I think there will be
some some browser security things you
know those flags to alter eyes because
nowadays it doesn't have and this is one
of the reasons why it's not well
supported just on firefox and chrome
chrome canary which was i was using and
where to use this you know I usually
show this example in people were like
okay that's really really crazy but
what's the the real use case for this
imagine you are going outside and then
you have this this huge light on your
phone and then you cannot read so this
is something very common what if we
could just detect that and say to the
user hey I notice you're on a very
bright place do you want me to tweak the
contrast of the application so you can
read it better so this is one thing you
can do or if you're on your bed I guess
everybody went through that situation
already you can just say hey I notice
you're in a dark room do you want me to
just change my UI to a dark theme so so
that's a very nice user experience kind
of thing that you can do the other one
is the battery status so now the the web
pages can detect the how you how your
battery is you know if I just connect my
computer I know if it's charging or not
if my batter using 60% or so
percent you can detect that for both
mobile and desktop devices this one is a
little bit different it's more like a
promise based API you can get the the
battery from the Navigator and then you
can you have the the battery object and
then you can detect events from there
and now I can detect if the level of my
battery changed or not in showing and
show that information the browser
support is not very good but ok it's
getting there and where to use this so
do you guys play pokemon go yes how is
the battery for Pokemon go not good
right
imagine if Pokemon go was written in on
the web and imagine you could just put
some information saying hey you got like
23 minutes remaining to catch pokemons
go recharge or like or imagine you have
like a dashboard or you know those
really long forms that there's like
terms of inputs that you need to fill
out
imagine if you could detect if the
battery is dying and tell the user had
no the battery's dying I'm gonna save
this information the local storage so
there plenty of use cases plenty of
ideas that you can play with and there's
so much more things going on on the web
there's web components and inside is
umbrella there's like templates shadow
Dom HTML imports custom elements so many
stuff you have progressive web apps
service workers push notifications web
Bluetooth web NFC there's so so many
api's and I'm just gonna show those
those last three those are more for the
future
the first one is web assembly so now we
have this low-level programming language
that we can put it on the web and the
use cases for that are those really high
performance applications the browser
support is not very good it's under
development
everything would probably change
like a week a month for a year so I
wouldn't say go play with that or put it
in production you can play of that but
not in production and you can do some
amazing things like this so check out
the performance for deserts
I don't know how you feel about this but
like this kind of thing running on the
web it's pretty insane and we also have
web VR which you can connect devices
like the oculus rift ooh the Google
cardboard and have this whole mersive
experience with we are the browser
support is getting there as well
but we already saw like so many good
examples for web VR and I will
definitely recommend a frame for for
doing that nowadays and we also have the
gamepad API so now you can connect a
game controller using USB and then
playing with your controller on your
application so the API it's you detect
this gamepad connected event and then
you can have plenty of game pads
connected so we're just gonna get the
first element on this array and then we
can you can get information like the
idea of this gamepad how many buttons it
has all those things and after you
connected the gamepad they're not it
there are no events for when you clicked
on a button do this so you have to use
requestanimationframe so we can use
requestanimationframe which if you are
already building a game you probably are
using this already so you we can call
this function this game loop function
using requestanimationframe and then we
can detect how many buttons it pressed
or not which was the button that pressed
and then moves like my character on the
game it's one side or to the other and
there's some really really nice
additions to this specification that is
coming like including those web vr
controllers is one of the things and
game pads that has such enabled on it so
that's pretty read the browser support
it's not bad you know you can probably
use it nowadays you can always fall back
to the to the
keyboard it's not something that it's
gonna ruin your entire experience and I
created this Nintendo emulator for the
stock so we basically have some does
anybody has like a playstation
controller or Xbox controller you know
okay I have one but it's but it's a
Nintendo controller okay so let me
connect this thing and let's play Super
Mario okay let's see if it's working
okay yeah
[Music]
where are you and hey okay I'm just a
nervous
now we're not going back to to the
ghosts okay so like the web is this
whole magic place right there's so many
things going on and it's just crazy like
every day there's a new - every day
there's a new library every day there's
a new API but it's it's just magic and
like most of the times we are just like
going to work doing the same thing or
we're doing new things but it's not like
completely different from what we do
already so you know the advice that we
heard earlier about side projects I
think that's really really a good advice
because we're often on a comfort zone
doing the things we are used to but
there's a lot of things on this magic
side where you can learn more you can
experiment more and you guys already did
the first step because you already came
to this conference so I'm assuming you
want to get out of the comfort zone but
it will require like tomorrow Sunday
whatever you know playing with that
working with those things it doesn't
need to be any web API can be anything
web pack whatever you want to choose but
yeah that's my message for you and thank
you so much
[Applause]